se piaciuto questo nuovissimo video sono
solo quello che fai vito so che chi deve
essere comunque ragazzi allora da una
vita e mezza fu faccio video su aim brad
che quel gioco dove devi muovere il
tosto e laratore mi ha fatto fa migliori
di quello perché non c'erano novità
tranne il fatto che è uscita una roba
che non sapevo ci fosse non avevo idea
fortunatamente forse che è la capra c'è
nel senso c'è la modalità simulator su
aim brad che io non capisco come sia
possibile prova bene prendetela lo scopo
di sta roba a quanto pare è di riuscire
a spaccare tutto
nel minor tempo possibile il fatto è che
va beh credo che siate capendo già
perfetto come questo questo questo il
casinò devo trovare il modo del sito di
muoverli natale non è che la capone che
si muove la capra a degli spasmi le di
spasmi dall'agosto notato di che tex che
comunque mi rende felice almeno quest
che o almeno due minuti per provare fa
sta roba ma non come come score salto
come faccio le cose
ami attacco ok allora niente a chi è
tutto chiave certo adesso spiegatemi
fisicamente come sia possibile che una
una capra si appiccichi alle cose sa
cosa non l'ho capita vabbè anche
effettivamente anche se il pane si
appiccica le robe non è proprio fisico
però vale dunque ho sempre desiderato
avere una capra in cucina la cosa
divertente che io vorrei provare a
descrivere quello che faccio ma non
trovo le parole per farlo cioè la lingua
attaccata alla mensola per cortesia per
cortesia il 7 di poteri luogo no ok è sì
vabbè devo fare 20 milioni per avere la
cioè non è possibile noi andiamo al
giorno dopo vediamo cosa riesca a fare
già tanto che ho preso la del dato anche
un po di là ti sto gioco no perché non è
solo difficile da capire a livello
fisico non anche è anche la cosa come
questa e la cosa triste va bene dov'è il
nome cosa va bene non fa niente non
facevano devo spaccare le co non capisco
anche su cosa potrei spaccare il posto
poco tempo che ciò mi stava avviando
anche la famiglia comunque sono 6
milioni e ragazzi spaccare ste robe è
stato utile
c'è molto di più dell'altra mappa
attenzione potrei anche puntare ai 20
milioni qua potrei anche puntare ai 20
radio fattibile
non so come mai fattibile basta che
continua a menare le stesse cose che mi
muovo come con gli spasmi sulle stesse
cose sono a posto cioè teoricamente
questa la tattica che era la stessa di
quando ero bambino per chiedere a mia
madre lo peso kimber comunque la stessa
l'obiettivo è quello che si sa fare più
con do possibili perché più combo fi e
più punteggiati da c'è serve caso
qualche brand per sponsorizzare il mio
canale sta guardando questo video ecco
guardane un altro perché spero non
capisci come come investire sui propri
geni e console giochi simili al potevo
fare molto difficile la prossima
riprovarci un secondo no perché nave
facciamo il giorno dopo ma stavolta ho
capito come come fare le combo buone
quindi stavolta dovrei fare stanza da
letto subito subito sulle europee
impilate che sono quelle che fanno più
punti vai vai le coop
non ho ancora capito bene come mi dovrei
muovere ma chi se ne frega bene bene con
bava netta con la manetta si prefetto
questo volevo perfetto perfetto ancora
ancora ancora 2 milioni non è tantissimo
prima volta sto meglio l'aspetta
provvedere e pieno di roba infilata
ragazzi satana programmato sto gioco
scusate ok perfetto il 31 dovevo fare
sono riuscito a farlo e che incredibile
che in genere non funziona così
specialmente nei giochi tipo questi sono
a 3 milioni di punti se l'è spesso
arrivare sulla scrivania siamo a posto
ok mi sono lanciato attenzione questa è
buona questa è buona per il punteggio
ragazzi questa è buona per il punteggio
spero che nessuno
mamma gara che a casa mia non la tengo
così e la tengo meglio soprattutto
adesso che mi sta facendo again in groom
devo potevo non spaccare tutto magari ok
4 milioni faccio schifo
vabbè
le sole sono morto sotto scrivania bene
e rimarrò qua perché non mi posso
togliere ok perfetto perfetto domanda
resto l'ultima pila perfetto mamma mia
che congo pazzesca farlo lui quanto ciò
4 milioni e quattrocento madonna non
escono anche a raggiungere i miei
scritti questa roba perché sarà molto
difficile ragazzi spetta agli altri
l'extra andiamo al bagno è comunque
veramente un cos'è ma come io voglio
sapere ma più che altro più nella fisica
voglio sapere come 6 16 st situazione
giro se vogliono veramente capire cosa
ti ha portato qua cosa sia forzato cosa
sei ubriaco nella vasca spiega vuole
problema
ok ok un pubblico così un po più di con
buchi di como che vedo che sei altro
mamma mia che disastro
vai vai vai a fare di più ancora di più
rapidi che sei lì madonna quanto per
quanti problemi
ok che 10 milioni in una sola bozzo ha
fatto lega passetto va bene sono
soddisfatto per quello che ho fatto
prima non è male ok ora 16 anni fa la
stessa cosa però con le altre cose di
intorno è meglio perfetto per mamma mi
ha fatta ho fatto un sacco di punti guai
ragazzi rispetto alle altre cose
riuscisse a salire a far fuori anche
questi perfetto ho fatto un casino
milioni più ho fatto vedere tutta la
credenza fra ferone mamma ora che
saranno un talento queste cose veri che
era era in prince e con la mia persona e
io lo dicevo sono mi credevo che avrei
fatto i soldi spaccando le cose in casa
io te lo dicevo già da piccolo ho fatto
un sacco rara daino la vede che ho fatto
un sacco a rega ma quanto come lo fa 18
milioni ci ero quasi arrivato gatti ma
bensì non è male è sempre più alto di
gotiche preso scola io quindi va bene
così
la cosa che mi fa ridere che non mi
carica a livello perché larga e ragazzi
veramente erano parole non mi carica
all'interno
ag sono contento lo abbiano fatto una
collaborazione con grossi mulè dr
comunque anche magari con con sergio non
potevano fare il saggio simulator fet
così muletto sarebbe stato interessante
da vedere però va bene già forse ci
limitiamo a questo che dite ragazzo è
come hanno fatto verso di staccarla
spiega miss partite è un fatto cose ho
fatto cose che non volevo però non fa
niente va bene almeno renditi utile
farvi fare i punti che lo sta facendo si
sa fa caldo ma sta facendo roma non so
cosa sia ragazzi ragazzi ora è tutto per
tutto per giorno no non ho idea di cosa
stia facendo la sta facendo europa 17
milioni 18 milioni di punti
non ho idea di cosa abbia fatto lega non
ho idea 20 milioni in una porta sola non
so neanche cosa ho fatto ho rotto gioco
senza volerlo ottimo è stato tutto
americani sta roba che non è più
affinato per sbaglio va bene ok spacchi
ed è questo lo sapevo giardino giardino
credo che sia il più difficile perché
almeno le cose fuori non ci sono da
rompe però posso buttare giù tutto
ci credo io nello staccare robe ci credo
guardalo no che c'era ancora della roba
varia non fa niente punteggio milionario
vai ancora ancora ancora ancora che
cederà rompere quasi ancora ok
spaccatutto che decadere tutto tipo
igienica ok no no no che ne soffocano
niente mai perfetto perfetto questo
volevo ho diretto sugli stato bravo la
cosa che come ho fatto
come ho fatto per chiedere roba lì come
come porta per chiedere lo bacio non è
possibile come fanno non c'è un anti
arrivato va bene fa niente
l'impero facciamoci domanda la gara è
già difficile ho già perso il punteggio
massimo non so come ma va bene e c'è
ancora un minuto ho rotto tutto dopo
divenne a spaccare le stesse bottiglie
da due ore o che va bene eccolo ho fatto
la sua tutto ciò pazzesco questo come
ragazzi sono un fenomeno sto gioco ci
sono pian piano se notate mi sono sempre
più chi lava come allora ok ok perfetto
ottieni un punteggio di 18 milioni potrò
prendere anche di più porca vacca
ragazzi questo era così un writer per
brad in realtà è [ __ ] sta cosa perché
hanno fatto solo unione di giochi spero
vi sia piaciuto il rigore che non potevo
non parla sarò bacia veramente iscritta
nel mio canale cioè proprio perfetta
dove vi sia piaciuto ragazzi questa
regione non mi piace anche la risorsa
quindi data notizia né ci ha proseguito
dove si fa conobbe con una capra faccio
video dal 2012 pensate che come ho fatto
a far carriera io non lo so
[Musica]